pop la famille loin monsieur et madame
boulanger la famille goujon madame
jeannine et sa fille
les lames noise monsieur le maire madame
et monsieur nikolov ce qui est leur fils
[Musique]
assoiffé de nature l'homme moderne a fui
la ville
il s'est installé à la campagne là il a
retrouvé la solitude
les larges horizons
l'air pur et la douceur des matins
[Musique]
[Rires]
là il a pu laver ses fatigues et ses
soucis dans un sommeil gré par là il a
pu oublier la hantise du temps
[Musique]
il se retrouver en harmonie avec son
semblable
son frère le progrès et la qui veillent
et l'entourent de ses soins merci
deux dirigeants fonctionnaire lui
apportent les messages du coeur et les
nouvelles du monde
[Applaudissements]
c'est ici un de ses blogs parmi d'autres
il a cet avantage de n'être pas atteint
de gigantisme comme ses voisins les gens
qui l'habitent n'en vis pas moins chacun
dans sa coquille ou plutôt dans sa boîte
[Applaudissements]
m
cependant là comme ailleurs l' aventure
peut surgir et venir tirer par la manche
des gens paisibles et qui s'appelle
comme vous et moi
le maire boulanger ou bouchons goujon
paul bougeant le voici
il se lève tôt et les marchands forains
[Musique]
l'engin madame bouchon matile je pense
j'ai pas fait attention
pourquoi tu mets la radio va pour
embêter le bassin qui fait marcher la
sienne jusqu'à minuit il est chaud je
n'essaie de soulever il y a en effet des
petits goujons 8 ans et 10 ans
7h15 quand ils ferment attouchements sa
porte celui là monsieur bhl loin il est
chef comptable et de deux ne t'énerve
pas michel madame loin blanche loin ce
qui permet à son mari de l'appeler db
other de tendresse tu verras que là
encore me mène quant à gérard alors j'ai
fini
gérard blouin vingt ans après planning
chez moi qu'il fait passer le premier ce
matin
non mais t'as déjà vu un planning qui
soient respectés toit aux noms sont
fichés mon tour
juste un petit coup de brosse pas pour
les démêlés sophie bloin 18 ans bon
alors fait vite
je téléphone non mais non sans face
c'est le réveil du guerrier
philippe lanone un sportif et matane
sa remise en jeu dans la manche et
reseller tu as dit pendant la veillée
brusquement
j'aime pas sortir trop vite de mon rêve
dit de suite que la réalité 2 déçoit
oui je pense qu'il m'aime pas brad hand
on allume plus tôt la radio celle des
autres te suffit plus
[Musique]
dominique boulanger instituteurs et
jeunes mariés comme on peut voir puisque
c'est lui qui a préparé le petit
déjeuner jacqueline boulanger
institutrice les niveaux belle endormie
déjà le prince charmant
c'est le petit chaperon rouge avec le
lait le beurre et les tartines monsieur
nick nikolov ski à val himiko il se
couche tard et se lèvent de m c'est un
artiste un musicien miok période
pourquoi as-tu fait sonner le réveil je
ne veux pas fait ce dimanche il sonne
c'est le téléphone des voisins dis donc
tu devrais aller voir si johnny est
réveillé je crois qu'il a quelque chose
à faire ce matin j'ai fait mon chéri
johnny johnny leur fils jean dit johnny
il n'a pas encore choisi sa direction
dans la vie il y en a trop ils hésitent
jeudi matin sur le samho b eh bien mon
chéri
[Musique]
les petites filles sont réveillés madame
janioud il y aurait qu un roman dans sa
vie que ça ne nous étonnerait pas un
roman vieux de 18 ans et dont les
pilotes s'appelle vallée tu sais que
c'est passionnant ya suspense
extraordinaire si je m'étais goûter
tueur élus toutes les nuits france est
commode pour réviser son courtois qui
bavarde elle brute autour vous donneront
leur aval à celui d'à côté mais là comme
ça
[Musique]
enfin monsieur le maire célibataire on
sait trop ce qu'il fait sinon qu'il
écrit qu'il voyage est toujours très
élégant et une jolie voiture est bien
cet immeuble paisible va devenir le
centre des tranches d'activité la radio
des fois qu'on l'entendrait pas tout
commence ce matin là celle inoffensif
monsieur blois bonne nouvelle jean
pierre va passer caporal-chef regardent
ils m'envoient sa photo gd forme lui va
bien
et
mais que fait tempère l'entend pas
michel tu pars déjà mais j'ai beaucoup
de travail les statistiques de fin
d'année des mesures approuve les mesures
oui je serai même peut-être un peu en
retard pour le dîner ne t'inquiète pas
michel we n'ont rien à voir on chez
pouvoir ce soit au revoir c'est fini at
il rappelé est une permission mois
prochain qui ça jean-pierre voyant un
homme tant mieux qu'est-ce qui annonce
ne va pas ton père d'être qui est en ce
moment à pourquoi tu pleures et blizzard
instable c'est peut-être le printemps le
printemps les temps plein hiver tu sais
lui il fait toujours des prévisions
allant pêcher en eau j'ai pas envie de
rire tiens il ne m'a même pas fait de
petits signes il est préoccupé par son
travail
oh non non ça c'est pas normal et puis
j'ai surpris les choses à oui quoi et
bien hier j'ai trouvé deux oeufs durs
dans la poche de son pardessus des oeufs
durs et bien il avait eu un petit creux
elle est un des ordures cassé et
raccommodé avec du scotch à et bien
n'avait plus fin il n'a pas voulu les
laisser perdre il est plutôt économe
dans son genre hier c'était une
enveloppe avec des mégots cui qui ne
fument pas tu crois qu'ils les avaient
ramassé dans la rue et en prix et ce
matin j'ai vu qu'il avait dans sa
serviette une carte du moyen-orient
il était entré deuxième bureau au au
deuxième bureau ton père
non non je plaisante pas j'en dors plus
t'en fais pas avec un type comme papa ça
peut pas être graves
n'empêche qu'il m'a dit qu'il rentrerait
tard ce soir et qu'il a glissé dans sa
poche mon mètre ruban le maître
aurez-vous oui même que c'est à double m
eh bien tu sais ce qu'on va faire
ce soir je demande à mon patron de me
lâcher une demi heure plus tôt tu viens
me chercher et on coince papa la sortie
de son bureau au nom trompeur comprend
l'accès pour le surveiller non parce
qu'on ne se montrera pas et on le filera
en douce comme dans un film policier non
non ça ça ne se fait pas au contraire ça
se fait beaucoup
tu lui as bien fait les poches alors
sophie pardon maman
alors ok
si tu crois comme ça au moins tu en
auras le coeur net
tu voi x or à l'heure habituelle
[Musique]
parce qu'ils pas par là je peux
peut-être marchette tulle approche
toujours pas faire cet exercice
[Musique]
dieu sait bien ce que j'avais
en
ma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
block des escaliers 15b quelques
cellules parmi beaucoup d'autres d'une
ville dortoir très anonyme nous savons
déjà que les germes d'une étrange
épidémie semble s'être déposé ici
les premiers symptômes de la maladie ont
été notées chez le plus inoffensif de
tous les locataires celui du second
monsieur beloin bon moment c'est ça tu
as découvert donc trop tôt fut là pour
te faire plaisir ça lui fait pas un
graphisme
michel oui je leur ai parlé tout à
l'heure quand tu auras fini ta toilettes
et à gymnastique et joris tout de suite
[Musique]
elle bien au chaud apparemment
vous
[Musique]
c'est attention c'est très chaud ici
beaucoup de mes choix mais qu'est ce que
tu as je t'avais prévenu
moi quand j'ai rien sinon un excellente
appétit tu te souviens
oui tout à fait bien oui alors explique
moi ce que c'est que ça c'est deus et
des jeux avec deux avec du scotch et oui
j'ai des choses que tu vois mais qu'est
ce que ça veut dire et vous et les bouts
de cigarettes dans ta poche si fière de
toi tu as mis à fumer en cachette les
nombres libye et la carte du
moyen-orient tu veux partir tu veux nous
quitter un nom bien vide et celui
imaginé qu'il va être partout
bon alors maintenant est-ce que tu va
m'expliquer expliquer quoi à tout tient
l'arbre par exemple tu mesures des
arbres maintenant as-tu jeu c'est une
forme de toujours tout savoir sur fille
est partie elle s'en va enfin je veux
parce que ce fille âgée pour lui faire
une surprise avait expliqué au revoir ce
soir on va ma chérie salut beauty tu te
coiffe avec un aspirateur maintenant ça
vaut mieux de laisser le terrain en
friche tu crois pas je ne dis rien
suffit mais non mais non
alors tu crois qu'elle se situera ça pas
forcément tunac est arrêté en descendant
il vanté oui au revoir bébé
brawl michel bois c'est pas ici et
messieurs je crois que c'est au deuxième
étage oui je sais je reviens c'est moi
michel bull ah bah je me disais aussi
votre visage n'est pas inconnu
forcément parce que tous les deux il
arrive que oui bien sûr
bon bah qu'est ce que je peux faire pour
vour intérim monsieur je me rangerai
voilà c'est ça va vous paraître un peu
bizarre mais bouge at instituteurs des
choix donc je voudrais qu'on dit c'est
comme ça tout de suite sans trop
réfléchir
qu'est-ce que je vous rappelle que vous
me rappeler oui dit au hasard je sais
pas moi marché oui marché mais pas comme
un poulet pas tout excuser moi notre
voisin du second monsieur loin il me
posait une sorte de devinettes à ce que
je crois comprendre oui voyez voilà je
vais vous dire il il s'agit de là tout
de suite sans réfléchir sans respirer
qui suis-je
mais voilà qui suis-je mais ça je le
sais et puis ça ne veut pas dire non
mais apparaître monsieur pigeon qui
suis-je la pause au chai la venue de ben
oui tout de suite
y a pas d'erreur possible c'est la
marseillaise de rudes la marseillaise
vite dit et si c'était le génie de la
bastille et en du tout génie de la
bastille est comme ça sur un pied tenez
c'est là c'est la numéro deux celle-là
numéro 4 1 qu'est ce que vous en dites
au passage jean dit rien parce que je
sais pas mais alors le numéro 3 ça c'est
la liberté
c'était plus facile je vais me faire
comprendre qu'il s'agit de statut
célèbre trajectoire dans ce cas cette
pause pourrait tête et celle de
l'héraklès à rebours d'elle irak laisse
savourer bien une scène ah oui c'est
vrai c'est un peu compliqué quand même
c'est qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que
c'est ça n'arrivera qu'à c'est-à-dire
hercules sculpté par bourdelle
ah bah oui oui bien oui bien sûr alors
là tout cas on a tous le numéro un c'est
la marseillaise de rudes
le numéro 3 la statue de la liberté à
new york le numéro 2
génie de la bastille et celle ci qui
restait à identifier serait selon
monsieur boulanger l'héraklès de
bourdelle le dit donc si je comprends
bien le fait aussi à ça que j'essaie
pardon c'est vrai monsieur des portes
courant vous ne verrez pas assez à dire
que j'allais faire quand vous avez je
crois comprendre qu'il s'agit d'un
concours dont les questions sont chaque
jour différentes et donc celle
d'aujourd'hui concernent des statuts à
identifier si vous aviez commencé par là
tout ce dont on peut rêver
il y a six premiers grands prix parmi
lesquels les six premiers gagnants
pourront choisir
oui ce qui m'a décidé c'est
l'appartement fille doit bientôt se
marier ouais c'est la maison de campagne
à cause des gosses si ça vous tente
bah on pourrait faire équipe quoi à
trois on aurait plus de chance
attendez je vais pas laisser le journal
voit aujourd'hui voilà bon ben je me
sauve la bauxite excusez-nous et pouvait
encore merci
alors dites-moi les objets religieux 2,2
à la majorité 3gp l'expérience et bien
oui les mégots et ça ça fait 7
cigarettes et bien voilà j'en suis sûr
parce que j'ai fumé plus d'un paquet en
une heure pour vérifier et je peux vous
dire que l'arbre la circonférence est de
1 mètre giraud s'est dit moi c'est un
arbre du midi votre arbre ça j'ai pris
les mesures et dites-moi les poteaux
indicateurs je crois avoir trouvé une il
faut encore que je vérifie habite mois
le numéro 5 le moteur rage alors là le
mode heure locale à joe kals le moteur
des vacances au japon pour deux
personnes au moins dont les voyages de
noces du poteau fuji yama cérémonie dite
et les geishas sept samouraïs toi guy
janicot parce qu'il ya toujours un piège
croyez pas forcément si les pas de piège
ça serait trop facile par exemple si un
jour pose une question simple 1 et 1 ça
fait combien rien ça fait deux cabanons
comme en ont un plus un ça fait deux
1 et 1 100 payante et voilà vous êtes
tombé dans le rouge c'est vrai faux
répète juin à doha dépêche toi on a déjà
la bourre à madrid dans la norme qui
pourrait nous dépanner question moteur
il est mécano dans un garage
oui
rapidement
[Applaudissements]
très vite la barre monsieur boujan et
monsieur besoins vos voisins de palier
alors aujourd'hui une petite question à
vous plonger c'est pour la fuite d'eau
non c'est pour un concours quoi oui mais
voilà il s'agit de savoir si avec les
pièces représentées ici là on peut
reconstituer un moteur et si ce moteur
peut tourner alors vous figurer que je
peux vous dire ça comme ça
du premier coup d'oeil complices mais
dites donc vous prenez pour cendrillon
ma parole
et puis encore projet au pardon s'agit
pas de répondre tout de suite mais on
voulait vous proposez c'est d'entrer
avec nous dans le coup pour le concours
à les concours c'est bidon et compagnie
qui pensent à et il ya des lots
magnifiques ya un appartement un voyage
au japon une maison de campagne
non non ce qu'il faut à monsieur lannoy
sépare ça y est pour quelque chose qui
bouge jeunes il ya un une caravane un
bateau
quel genre de bateau c'est un chris
craft 120 chevaux
[Applaudissements]
bon bah écoutez je regarderai ça puis je
vous dirai ça soir en rentrant dans la
retourner naturellement d'ores et déjà
vous pouvez vous considérez comme
faisant partie de l'équipe 1 re ou et
ben on verra on verra lors d'années mois
plus tôt la photo
non cette attention parce que je n'ai
pas encore découper la vignette bon
alors bah alors ça va il tourne donc la
réponse est oui
la réponse est oui j'aurais cru qu'il
manquait une petite chose comme ça là
bas une petite chose comme ça c'est une
bielle un moteur à dossier d'al yah
globale alors chilhac de bienne pardon
mais alors la la voilà une bonne recrue
pour votre concours
oui bah c'est un écrivain il doit tout
connaître c'est pas tellement le genre
coopérative pourra toujours lui demander
alors là on voyait plutôt votre femme
pourquoi vous verrez pourrait faire
marcher votre moteur un époux et
pourquoi il pourrait pas marcher ce
moteur parce qu'il n'y a pas d'essence
et maman en or qu'ils ont bien
représenté un bidon d'huile alors on
peut quand même se demander si le piège
mais oui il ya un piège je l'avais dit
il ya toujours un piège donc la réponse
la même annonce les noms quoi vous
croyez
mais oui j'essaye toujours de vous
possédez ce qu'il faut c'est être plus
malin que voilà tout alors monsieur lâm
noise vous entrez dans l'équipe
bon voilà sur vous la photo du bateau
comment donc vous faire part ça tout de
suite
tanner la tasse en vache ou pas mal ont
conclu cette armoire normande mesure 1 m
82 au 1 m 20 de large et 0 mètre
soixante de profondeur l'ensemble des
objets ci dessus tout il y trouve et
passe bas ça ça c'est une question à
laquelle on ne te répondent qu'en
faisant l'expérience c'est bon ça dépend
si facile d'abord il faut réunir tous à
commencer par moi ouais vous n'avez pas
une armoire normande alors ça ça
m'étonne alors donné une 7 avoir une
arme à revendre
ah oui on aimerait bien trouver
quelqu'un avec une erreur normande même
célébrer le fait normal et les stocks et
les sites ont laissé des miettes toi si
tu veux la maison conseil je te
conseille de promesses d attendre y
offrit la maison de campagne la maison
de campagne est en espagne la maison
allons trouver un monsieur danoise lui
l'a sûrement est normalement oui je
croyais qu'il a une tête à ça d'avoir
normands voient sûrement pas en ma
faveur des armoires nous on est meublée
tout en voix tendre trop vous voulez
voir en tout cas vous pourrez toujours
fournir l'escabeau a rien d'inquiétant
tout moment ça escargots c'est d'accord
maintenant il ya la tête je sais
peut-être de serre vous avez une tête de
certes au près ce que j'ai l'air d'avoir
une tête de serpent vincent s'est jamais
dit mais le riad navarro m eh ben dites
donc ça date des croisades ce truc là
nous on sait pas meublé à la foire à la
ferraille la réflexion de vente il
assure de ma femme n'y en aurait pas un
comme ça oui oui tante yvonne a
exactement le même tu crois que nous le
peintre est aussi en moi c'est moi qui
lui demandent à vouvoyer bombe alors
c'est réglé pour le baromètre qu'est-ce
qu'il ya encore un matelas une valise
une cage à oiseaux bon tout ça ça va un
mannequin un mannequin genia à la cave
bravo madame un ours en peluche au
passage je prendrais celui des gosses
bas le globe terrestre chercher la
sphère de l'instituteur a priori à la
dame-jeanne il fait voir à belvès eu du
rez de chaussée on a eu une transformer
en lampe eco manche et touche-à-tout
dehors ont le même poids à près de la
fenêtre
y'a qu'à lui emprunter vont là bas ça
c'est une autre histoire
je suis là c'est un ours d'une ourse
bien léché mais un ours quand même
demandé au gardien appuis alors le
gardien on fait pour s'y connaît bon et
puis il ya toujours la tête de cerf ça
alors là tu essaies radon nombreuses
robes blanches ne dis pas que tu sais il
ya une tête de l'est pourtant non non
non ont d'ailleurs ce qu'il faut trouver
avant tout celle armes
tandis que vonn elle en a paru non enfin
si mais je crois pas qu'elle pourrait
l'arrêter
d'abord elle habite les gars est noble
c'est une armoire comme ça qu'il vous
faut oui mais il est venu non pas chez
madame jeanne yu na radio 1 c'est sûr
c'est la dame du rez-de-chaussée tu sais
pas quelle fille de la jeune fille mais
on pourrait peut-être lui demander non
mais oui elle est très vieille vous
savez cet homme un peu de famille et je
la tiens de ma mère bien entendu madame
delattre et orion avec les plus grands
jega s'appauvrit bien longtemps que les
10 cd je voulais dire l'armoire
évidemment on l'a déménagera nous mêmes
tous ah oui et puis on mettrait dedans
tout petit caramel et c'est donc ainsi
il s'agit d'un conte brit-brit c'est
très amusant moi j'adore les devinettes
et tout ce qui est un petit peu
mystérieux ah oui et si on vous
proposait d'entrer dans l'équipe avec
nous oui avec ces messieurs et moi oui
il ya sans doute un lot qui vous je
dirais teulet par exemple la garde robe
de grand couturier
mais c'est merveilleux je travaillais
pas trop tôt vous savez en ce moment
mais ça pourrait abîmer vos yeux
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont enfin ma mère
dit d'ailleurs que les yeux c'est un
capital elle allait représenter votre
mère
qu'est-ce que vous étudiez exactement je
suis à l'école dentaire chez cathy pour
devenir dentiste
ah bon dentiste oui pourquoi pas et va
au chimiste
oui je suis à l'école de chimie
d'ailleurs je vous vois souvent le matin
je souffrais c'est curieux nous sommes
toujours dans le même wagon
le propos c'est pas vous qui auriez eu
l'idée pour l'armoire s'ils n'ont pas
beaucoup d'argent a trouvé une tête de
cerf une tête de cerf tu attends valérie
et oui un violon mais est ce que le
monsieur du premier n'est pas d'ironie
comme ça choquant j'habite en face
oui mais moi juste au dessus vous ne
pourriez pas à les emprunter
après un violent soit efficace
nous avons le nôtre aujourd'hui moi je
vais vous laisser à monsieur boulanger
vous avez bien vu c'est exactement le
petit nouveau à oui pourquoi nous allons
chez monsieur nico nico match le ski
enfin là où il faut absolument tout près
de son violon pour le congolais d'accord
avec 181 la chose beaucoup dû renouveler
fait le pain vous fait pas prier pour
être connaissez monsieur l'avesnois
jouer au foot pas je sais que ça
évidemment nous voulions voir monsieur
votre mari maintenant - et sans doute
mal choisi
mais pas du tout hantée pour merci c'est
gentil merci intérêts mais nous allons
le dérangeait pas dit où nous vous
attendions
oui mais oui lorsque vous voyez
aujourd'hui un élargissement dans ses
relations
incluez mon mari sur la visite
mais vous savez bien la scop aux
obligations messieurs comité syndical
protestation pétition non non non tout
simplement violon à vous n'aimez pas
violent non au contraire nous voulions
vous en prêter votre violon à vous
voulez jouer du violon non je vous
remettre dans l'armoire dans la moi
alors explications voilà voilà
il s'agit d'un concours
au fait je n'aime pas beaucoup les
concours ça me rappelle trop celui du
conservatoire mais j'avais été recalé
non je tire su brillamment mais toute ma
vie j'ai joué du galon alors que
j'aurais pu créer composent les irriter
pain stanislas écouter ces messieurs
c'est vrai pardon alors concours que
nous avons décidé mes camarades et moi
de faire en équipe une équipe très bien
c'est très bien et ayant besoin d'un
violent nous avons pensé que vous
pourriez peut-être nous en prêter un
larry est entré dans l'équipe
voilà comme vous croyez que je mets
didier yah l'état truc à gagner un
journal il ya un appartement bien un
bateau voyage au japon
les gens comprennent une maison de
campagne pour mon grand artiste poule
est composée en tête loin du bruit au
sein de la nati c'est que voyez-vous ma
femme aussi voudrait une maison de
campagne a pas une bagnole dans les lots
c'est bien sûr avec une caravane pour le
camping
maintenant on peut qu à répartir les
lots bon alors j'avais su je dis pardon
abonnés alors au suivant à la
dame-jeanne là c'est exactement la même
ah oui ça c'est à croire que c'est celle
là qui a servi pour la photo du journal
où ce fut d'abord est une dame d'adam
celle ci ressemble à toutes les autres
vous n'aurez aucun mal à retrouver ses
semblables non parce que l'homme est
seul l'occasion nous a fait vraiment
désolé messieurs navré et il est une
chose à ce propos qui me surprend un peu
comment avez-vous su que je possède une
lampe de ce genre en pas c'est bien
simple quelques-uns d'entre nous on peut
vous voir le soir travailler sous la
langue
aucune indiscrétion certes voudrait bien
non plus ne pas reprendre à mal que je
vous refuse cette plan égyptien
ce que vous voyez on on avait décidé de
faire équipe suis désolé si navré de ne
pas pouvoir vous rendre socialiste
bonsoir monsieur je vous l'avais dit
c'est un ours mais mon sentiment ce
monsieur là veut faire le concours mais
pour lui tout seul vous avez vu sur son
bureau il y avait un journal bon c'est
pas parce qu'on les journaux mais il
n'empêche qu'on sait pas ce qu'il fait
et ça ça c'est louche à 10 dont j'ai
pensé si c'est une dame jeanne moi je
peux en avoir une parce que au garage il
nous livre là site dans des trucs comme
ça
travailler chez lameloise vous nous
dépanner c'est mon métier la journée à
la base nous avons à peu près le même la
voix la salle et voilà un renard du
travail d'équipé il ne manque plus que
la tête de cerf travail urssaf et tête
de cerf et dites moi monsieur blanc
est-ce que tout à l'heure
madame loin ne semblait pas dire que
robin non et je vois à quoi il faisait
allusion
chez mon patron qui a une passion pour
la chasse est fait et là il ya une heure
un trophée dans son bureau vais de toute
façon pas c'est une tête de cerf oui
alors son bureau dont mais enfin au
dessus ça me tenait il y tient comme ça
il pourra peut-être nous l'a prêté lui
ont jamais de la vie je lui demanderais
même pas alors on peut la lui emprunter
on ne sait pas quoi en apprendre on
l'apprend soir on la rapporte lendemain
matin
pantalon ni vu ni connu enfin je vous
prie de ne pas glisser des deux mois
votre appartement vous le voulez oui ou
non
oui bien sûr on alors il nous faut la
tête de cerf franco alors demain soir
d'accord je suis toujours d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as tu un cauchemar
cette digestion sans doute je donne un
petit peu de bicarbonate tu vois tu
aurais pas dû reprendre du lapin
[Musique]
au delà de manière vous devez pas une
clio tournant avec est brouillée alors
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et d'un coup de bol un presque devant la
porte c'est bien le 28 qu'il a dit oui
28 au deuxième étage
le tourneur et compagnies russes et
serbes ont encore douze minutes avant
l'heure h profitez en pour repérer la
loge du concierge
bah ça doit être lui qui est sur le pas
de la porte
bon alors les gars d'accord 1 1 vous le
l'entrepreneur 2 je passe un coup de fil
du bistrot en face si nécessaire pour le
faire rentrer dans son trou 3 vous le
neutraliser 4 je réceptionne la
marchandise si on accroche dans
l'opération terrestre on embraye aussi
sec sur le parachutage lui mais il
faudrait que nous examinions ces
contrats plus en détail
l'échelonnement des règlements semble
pouvoir être resserrée sur un temps plus
court après tout nous leur avons fait à
cette concession
nous verrons ça demain bien monsieur
guay voyons ça vous avez calculé le
pourcentage selon les nouveaux barèmes
bien entendu où chacun est invité à la
ferme machine est il faudra revoir nos
propositions je sais qu'il ya des
concurrents en ligne et on sera
peut-être amené ajuster au plus court où
on l affaire le sert à faire le 6 mai
l'affrètement de bois ou de boire à de
boire mais nous avons fait des offres
michel corboz il ne donne pas signe de
vie il faudra les relances et bien le
chien
de toute façon et selon l'état de new
balance nous aviserons sur la politique
à suivre
je pense qu'il faudra faire un
réajustement complet de nos opérations à
long terme avec lui la situation est
trop glissantes en ce moment pour
maintenir de pareils tous les ce compte
vous êtes bien d'accord avec moi
oui monsieur le cher monsieur direct
nous verrons le reste plus tard nous
semble un peu fatigué et monsieur blouin
nombreux jeunes irakiens juste
les balles de set reposez-vous la suite
à demain bonsoir checkmate attention le
signal
[Musique]
à vous de jouer
d'accord
bonjour monsieur
j villa et compagnie c'est bien ici ah
oui mais il ya plus personne dans les
bureaux ferment à china org bas c'est
bien ma veine pourtant j'ai fait vite
chat ou bras l'honneur demain matin oui
bah oui mais vous êtes le foncière ben
oui il sortit il semble que je vous
reconnais ah oui ou alors tu une
ressemblance
vous habitez l'apatam hépatites vous
n'êtes pas client de vous n'êtes pas
client du petit tabac au point chez nous
chez raoul
oui il fait quelquefois kivu pour le
tiercé mardi à césar
je peux téléphoner vous avez touché
quelques poireaux l'une soit on se dit
on fait déjà pas mal mais la semaine
dernière des mousses et c'est rageant
c'est passé les fautes sont encore là
comme un os mais non vous lis que j'ai
pas ici n'atteindra parra qui change et
des libraires correct en entrant dans
les banques et donc le tiercé vous vous
faites le scientifique au pif
j'ai tout essayé mais vous croirez si
vous voudrez un scientifique ou aux pays
bas c'est du pareil au même
4 le jour j'ai touché la deux ans
d'efforts et ben j'avais pris les
chiffres de la date de naissance de ma
femme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir madame vois pas qu'est ce qu'il
avance au large de bakassi freedom avec
une tête à nîmes a tué franchir yeux
mais si je vous le dis c'est comme qui
dirait un homme avec une tête de cheval
et puis un temps on a choisi la tête
hoballah l'on voit et ben ouais bien que
rien vous avez été victime de votre
imagination et bien moi je vous dis que
je les ai vus comme je vous vois il a du
sens au vairon les mouches trop ça se
fait plus beaucoup se font aussi des
mains vous n'auriez pas été par hasard
au cinéma ces jours ci si je suis athée
dimanche avec mon homme
il n'y avait pas de mousse sis est cédée
à suspense bon allons voir falah ben y'a
bien ses matchs tête d'animal mais
risque pas de chômer
f
goujon
allez vis ça vous remettra et 12 jo et
ça peut arriver les eaux pour ça des
choses et puis on pourra les voir céder
t&d à nice lens ou faut dire aussi que
de raconter mon truc austremoine rai uno
sur les martiens et tout allait à la
bonne vôtre à l'autre
eh ben ce sera la trop chaud qui
s'appelait il pourrait y avoir des
animaux partout faut dire aussi que tu
es pendant la guerre dont j'en avais
tout seuls quelques-uns à bas hamad et
anciens combattants
je me disais aussi jeudi dont c'est pas
vous la cbc pas vu ça j'ai la chiche et
moi parlons 14 18 la vraie à la vraie
[Musique]
la nama bonjour immédiat rien
ça m'aurait on peut dire qui la pleurent
leur retrait ah oui qu'est-ce qu'il va
mais là puisque c'est au nom nombre par
les cornes en dessous de ses passagers
sur sa jambe et non la voiture à vue
n'est pas ma voiture la voiture
on dirait un porte-manteau une
décoration originale peut-être un peu
austère pour une chambre au mieux
qu'elle n'aurait peut-être pas résisté
comme je suis de l'autre côté alors
j'aide un concours ça vous intéresse en
moi m'a tellement ya déjà un bon soir
mignonne bonsoir aussi mal élevé que
mourir tu devras lui demander aux
messieurs de prêter un livre le petit
chaperon rouge par exemple sera n'a
l'air de rien mais c'est instructif
ce que je vous fais volontiers dire à
vous jeunes hommes c'est le parfait
savoir-vivre rendez compte jamais touche
à notre nom larmoiement ça ça on n'en
sait rien essayons toujours on verra
bien
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
m
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
le pas
vous ne croyez pas que mais bien sûr le
biais oui le piège
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attendez attendez non non regardez la
photo la photo
pourquoi venez-vous qui est un violon
dans cette aiguille il n'y a pas de viol
rompt tente non mais galbraith
[Musique]
maman les brumes pourtant bien son
armoire
oui avec dépit tout autour et
[Musique]
je mesdames la réponse est oui
il ya une au café le quoi plaire mois
rectification la réponse est non
[Musique]